always the only only woman in the room
still walk-in only woman in the room and
there's a room full of white men usually
older thrills me just thrills me I just
I just love it usually the only black
person in the room also never really
concerned me because I don't look at
people through color I didn't get to be
where I am by and Who I am by looking at
the color of people's skin I really
literally took Martin Luther King at his
word and understand that the content of
a person's character and refused to let
anybody else do that to me so I love it
just love it and there's a wonderful
phrase by Maya Angelou from a poem that
she wrote called to our grandmothers
that she says when I come as one but I
stand as 10,000 so when I walk into a
room and particularly before I have
something really challenging to do or
I'm gonna be in a circumstance where I
feel I'm going to be you know up against
some difficulties I will literally sit
and I will call on that 10,000 I will
call on the ancestors I will call on
those people who've come before me I
will call on the women who forged a path
that I might be able to sit in the room
with all of those white men and love it
so much I I call on I call on that
because I know that my being where I am
and first of all being who I am and
where I am didn't come just out of
myself that I come from a heritage and
so I own that and I step into that room
not just as myself but I bring all of
that in that that energy with me